well formula one is something we're
talking about we're talking about racing
on and near the strip that's exciting
yeah and they could become a real
possibility sports director chris
matthews joining us with the latest
[Music]
well thank you yeah we first reported
last fall that a group of las vegas
movers and shakers were heading to
austin texas to talk with the formula
one officials and see how the sport
operates they did and came back wowed by
the weekend experience and now vegas is
in the mix to host one of the biggest
motorsports events on the planet
only f1 yeah race held in the us is in
austin it drew 400 000 fans formula
one's popularity is growing by leaps and
bounds tv numbers are up and that
netflix series on f1 called drive to
survive it's one of the most popular
shows on the streaming service officials
telling us there could be an
announcement on vegas hosting a race by
the end of the month now in two months
formula one will be racing in miami for
the very first time when formula one
racing makes its pit stop in vegas it'll
be the biggest sporting event our city
has ever hosted and the economic
benefits will certainly be off the
charts denise